[Musik]
bild ulrike
herrmann urteil des verfassungsgerichts
in karlsruhe und es geht um keine
geringere als ex kanzlerin angela merkel
kurzer rückblick anfang 2020 da verhalf
die afg erstmals mit ihren stimmen einem
ministerpräsident ins amt zwar in
thüringen ex kanzlerin merkel nannte den
vorgang unverzeihlich dass müsse
rückgängig gemacht werden die fdp regte
daraufhin klar ja und nun hat das
verfassungsgericht also sein urteil
gesprochen und der afg recht gegeben mit
ihren äußerungen zur
ministerpräsidentenwahl habe merkel die
rechte der afg verletzt haben wir uns
noch mal den genauen wortlaut von damals
an die kanzlerin war auf einer südafrika
reise
über dieses ministerpräsidenten war ein
einzigartiger vorgang der mit einer
grundüberzeugung gebrochen hat für die
cdu und auch für mich nämlich dass keine
mehrheiten mit hilfe der afd
gewonnen werden sollen da dies absehbar
war in der konstellation wie im dritten
wahlgang gewählt wurde muss man sagen
dass dieser vorgang unverzeihlich ist
und deshalb auch das ergebnis wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden muss zumindest
gilt für die cdu dass die cdu sich nicht
an einer regierung unter dem gewählten
ministerpräsidenten
beteiligen darf
es war ein schlechter tag für die
demokratie sei ein tag der mit den
werten und überzeugungen der cdu
gebrochen hat und es muss jetzt alles
getan werden damit deutlich wird dass
dies in keiner weise mit dem was die cdu
denkt und tut in übereinstimmung
gebracht werden kann daran wird in den
nächsten tagen zu arbeiten sein dass man
also die äußerungen der kanzlerin damals
unser bild parlament chef ralf schuler
der war eben bei dieser reise auch mit
dabei und es jetzt bei uns im studio
reife was genau bedeutet jetzt dieses
urteil also es ist der grösste schuss
den angela merkel im nachgang zu ihrer
kanzlerschaft gefangen hat eine der
wirklich brachial ssten
verfassungsrechtlichen übertritte wird
ihr hier amtlich bescheinigt vom
höchsten gericht das in letzter zeit
eigentlich eher freundlich umgegangen
ist mit der ära merkel auch mit den
crooner regelungen und einer ihrer
früheren unions fraktions vize
vorsitzenden sitzt ja als vorsitzender
und präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts stephan
harbarth in karlsruhe das ist schon sehr
brachial das ist vielleicht in der
geeste sieht es wie eine kleine
korrektur oder einen rüffel aus wenn man
sich aber die konstitutionellen
grundlagen der der bundesrepublik klar
macht angela merkel als kanzlerin ist
ein verfassungsorgan die länder
bundesrat sind auch ein verfassungsorgan
und ist kann nicht sein dass die
exekutive der merkel vor steht als
kanzlerin der den ländern irgendeinen
hinweis gibt sie war dort nicht als
bundeskanzlerin sie war sie war dort als
bundeskanzler die man nicht als
parteichefin das war damals schon
annegret kramp karrenbauer und auf einer
auslandsreise der bundeskanzlerin ist
sie auch kanzlerin und nicht
parteichefin sie hat weder irgendetwas
zu verzeihen was reguläre wahlen
hergestellt haben noch hat sie
anzuweisen etwas rückgängig zu machen
das war damals schon einen wirklich
brachialer vorgang es hat mich gewundert
dass es so lange gedauert hat das
aufzuarbeiten
das geht einfach nicht unter
verfassungsorgan in einem zivilisierten
start zumal man kann politisch jede
meinung vertreten aber dieser diese wahl
in thüringen ist regulär zustande
gekommen die afg hat jetzt durchgesetzt
dass ihre sie ihren ihren rechten
beschnitten worden ist denn sie durfte
selbstverständlich als kraft im landtag
den damaligen ministerpräsidenten
kemmerich wickeln das ist schon ein
ziemlicher rückschlag zumindest in einem
zivilisierten land wo es eine föderale
ordnung gibt die bisher eigentlich auf
ganz guten füßen stand was hat das
urteil denn jetzt konkret für folgen für
angela merkel ich meine sie ist ja nun
mal auch nicht mehr im amt es hat
konkret im grunde keine folgen weil sie
nicht mehr zurücktreten kann man kann
nichts für sie
also es hat sich in deutschland
eingebürgert dass viele verantwortliche
politiker verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber keine konsequenzen ziehen ich
glaube nicht dass sie zurückgetreten
wäre in der verfassungsrechtlichen
konsequenz ist dass ein ziemlicher
hammer das hätte sie auf jeden fall wie
man politisch so schön sagt schwer
beschädigt die wahl in thüringen wird
dadurch auch nicht noch einmal
aufgerollt werden es wird aber wirklich
ein interessantes schlaglicht darauf mit
welcher härte und auch sie sich damals
über alle gängigen juristischen regeln
hinweggesetzt hat denn die lagen auf der
hand sie weiß bei anderen gelegenheiten
ganz genau dass sie anderen
verfassungsorganen nicht rein regieren
darf das war 1 1 macht akt der als
solcher jetzt zurückgenommen worden ist
verfassungsrechtlich wirklich sehr sehr
bemerkenswert jetzt also ein machtwort
vom verfassungsgericht man muss
allerdings auch mal fragen was bedeutet
das jetzt für die afg es war ja jetzt
auch nicht ihre erste erfolgreiche klage
nein sie hat zum beispiel schon mal
dagegen geklagt dass horst seehofer auf
seiner webseite sich schwer abfällig
über die afg geäußert hat das durfte er
als innenminister damals als
verfassungsminister nicht und es setzt
so ein bisschen den rahmen dafür dass
auch im parteienstreit mit einer von den
meisten parteien
gemiedenen und und verabscheuten partei
nicht alles erlaubt ist sondern dass
recht und gesetz wenigstens in den
großen zügen einzuhalten sind und dafür
ist es eigentlich schon ganz wichtig das
mandat was die bürger abgeordneten
verlangen parteien auch im thüringer
landtag ist ein so hohes gut das man
nicht einfach als regierungschefin wenn
einem irgendetwas nicht passt sich
hinstellen kann und sagen machen wir
rückgängig ist nicht akzeptabel wir
haben hier gerade eben noch mal die
szenen von damals gesehen da wurden dann
auch blumensträuße unten sozusagen im
kemmerich dann vor die füße geworfen
unter anderem von spd mitgliedern auch
hier sehen was jetzt noch mal das hat
schon sehr hohe wellen geschlagen das
hat riesige wellen geschlagen weil es
natürlich eine regierung war an der
indirekt an deren zustandekommen die afg
beteiligt war und da waren sich
eigentlich alle anderen parteien einig
dass das nicht sein sollte solche sachen
mit denen vor hingeworfenen blumen finde
ich eher kindisch unter demokraten dann
gratuliert man nicht oder ähnliches aber
wir sind ja hier nicht in einer ehe wo
man mit mit porzellanteller nacheinander
wird sollte man übrigens auch gar nicht
das ist ein bisschen albern aber
rechtlich gesehen war das problem damals
das ist keine stabile mehrheit gab und
viele leute haben versucht zu tricksen
und dann hat sich ein kandidat gestellt
und hat ihr gesagt super stimmen wir
einfach mal zu und dann lasst sie sich
zerlegen das haben sie getan 34 habt
natürlich auch kemmerich angefragt was
er zu diesem urteil sagt und das hat er
uns hierbei bild exklusiv gesagt ich
möchte das urteil nicht näher bewerten
ich habe großen respekt vor dem gericht
seine einschätzung dass sein problem ist
natürlich dass er jetzt keinen triumph
an stimmen kann weil es war ein
schwieriger akt von dem sich auch die
seine parteiführung distanziert hat die
union hat schweren schaden genommen die
damalige parteivorsitzende ist als
geprügelte chefin wieder abgereist aus
thüringen also es hat nur blessuren
hinterlassen insofern nimmt er das
sichtlich mit genugtuung zur kenntnis
zeigt diese aber nicht
es wird für thüringen und für die
bundespolitik folgenlos bleiben im
engeren sinne aber es wird natürlich
zeigen auch im umgang mit der fdj ein
rechtlicher rahmen gewahrt bleiben
zumindest ein urteil mit signalwirkung
dankte lothar dann
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit
verfassungsrechtler ulrich battis schön
montag herr battis
guten tag guten tag sind sie überrascht
von diesem urteil
nein das ist nicht überraschend
es kommt hier auf das szenario an es war
im ausland vor einem staatsbesuch vor
schlangen hat die eben als kanzlerin
gesprochen wenn auch ihre wortwahl sind
wie wir ja gerade gehört haben sie immer
wieder nur auf cdu abgestellt hat aber
das wird über überwölbt dadurch dass sie
eben im ausland als kanzlerin auftritt
warum hat das verfassungsgericht so
lange gebraucht um das zu entscheiden
das ganze ist ja nun schon über zwei
jahre her die kanzlerin gar nicht mehr
im amt
nun das kann ich nicht beurteilen
das müssen sie das gericht fragen
aber es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass nach
zwei jahren eine es gibt andere
entscheidungen die ihr gehen nach vier
jahren
hat das denn jetzt irgendwelche
konsequenzen
oder ist das nur eine rüge und was
glauben sie trifft angela merkel das
auch persönlich
nein das hat keinerlei konsequenzen
jetzt für frau merkel
weder als ehemalige bundeskanzlerin noch
irgendwelche ansprüche entstehen dadurch
gegen sie aber es ist natürlich an tadel
durch das bundesverfassungsgericht dem
wir nicht gerne haben
einschätzungen von ulrich matthes
verfassungsrechtler besten dank ihnen